hey guys it's just seen in today's the
day vlog University is here this is an
event that I've been working on for the
past year but this has been basically
ten years in the making I thought of
this little show idea that I did on
YouTube over ten years ago and now it's
here it's an actual event people are
filling in the keynote is about to start
and I just want to give you guys a quick
little look and what's happening at vlog
University this weekend I could not be
more excited this is so I'm freaking
[Music]
[Applause]
jeanna blog universities here yes um
this is where my microphone is making
sure that she can hear me
you know how's it going we're good so
the professionals this is how they do it
good luck thank you
I don't know much else to say
[Music]
but that night you take it you put your
leg underneath your pillow while you're
sleeping the leg fairy comes and then
the next morning you look under the
pillow and you find a handicap parking
pass I just wanted to come because just
it's been such a big inspiration to me
and learning what I love to do from the
people who I look up to is honestly such
a surreal experience and I feel so
grateful I was able to attend I'm so
excited to learn more especially about
editing in Final Cut Pro it's just my
passion in life in creating content and
uploading content and building an
audience in learning the tools that
you'll be learning about today and
tomorrow there is no three strikes and
you're out you get as many strikes as
you want you strike out when you quit so
today is beginning we're gonna be
posting so much stuff on social media of
course on Instagram and Twitter so you
can follow me and also you can follow a
vlog University on Instagram and Twitter
as well I am just so excited and so
honored that everyone believed enough in
this event to come out and hang out
especially all of our speakers and
sponsors and just all of you guys for
even being there if you're not actually
here you guys are here
in my heart Jenna come here have some
words hello it's Jenna hi so it's crazy
cuz I was thinking when I started my
little keynote part I was talking about
how much stuff Jenna has put up with
over the years
oh yeah it's a lot it is a lot but this
this thing is here it is here well it's
crazy because I actually just realized I
was on YouTube for ten years ah so
that's a long time she made a little
ten-year montage it's gonna be in our
session we're doing that tomorrow so
yeah it's here
and I don't know what else to say other
than I'm excited and Jenna has a little
your speech oh my god I don't know I'm
here
okay that's the end this video
okay bye
wait we gotta show the vlog squad here's
our vlog squad I will just airdrop this
to you
Vick Connor and Tyler and Armando
oh my gosh I'm so excited and Jenna this
is so great okay
vlog squad new vlog you squad let's go
[Music]